l'année 2020 a commencé par du sport et
la traditionnelle conférence de presse
du paris nice le 8 janvier les
organisateurs annoncent une course au
soleil dans les yvelines pour la
douzième année consécutive au mois de
mars
au programme de cette édition des
départs de plaisir et chevreuse
il faut absolument qu'on trouve nous
organisateurs des terrains de jeux et
les yvelines nous offre la possibilité
donc de de mettre en place un terrain en
ce début d'année le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines accueille
pas de compétition cycliste mais le
salon de l'étudiant pour la première
fois habituellement organisée à
versailles l'événement au groupe 100
exposants ce 27 janvier
objectif répondre aux interrogations des
étudiants d'accueillir davantage
d'exposants et après il ya tout le côté
pratique où s'étaient pas pu s en ce
mois de janvier 2020 en parle également
politique dans les yvelines et des
élections municipales et son premier
tour programmé le 15 mars approche est
différente liste se dévoile au mois de
février commence par du basket une
rencontre à l'accent américain le 6
février deux écoles versaillais sainte
geneviève et auch s'affrontent dans un
match amical digne des plus grandes
ambiances universitaire américaine dans
la salle 1600 supporters all away c'est
le match de l'année là on a on attend ça
depuis deux mois
aulas a fait une semaine on pense plus
qu'à ça on a oublié toutes les maths et
la physique et où on est là pour gagner
le mois de février est également marquée
par l'organisation du salon de
l'agriculture porte de versailles a
rendez vous les politiques se pressent
chaque année pour un troisième année
consécutive les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine font
stand commun dans la perspective de leur
éventuelle fusion
les pressions des deux départements
était présent ce lundi 24 février les
yvelines ont près de la moitié de leur
territoire on l'agriculture doc c'est
non seulement un art de vivre une
qualité de vie mais c'est aussi une
dimension économique conscient
la première quinzaine de mars est
rythmée par le premier tour des
élections municipales le jour j le
dimanche 15 mars les partis et
mouvements politiques traditionnels ont
démontré leur force dans le département
le rassemblement de la droite et du
centre sort vainqueur de ce scrutin dans
les yvelines
statu quo en revanche pour la gauche à
cause des divisions quant aux parties la
république en marche il n'a pas réussi
son pari sur le territoire en parallèle
des élections des premiers cas de kobe
19 sont recensées sur le territoire des
yvelines et rendez vous sportifs et
culturels sont annulées au reporter la
course paris nice est également perturbé
avant le départ de l'épreuve le dimanche
8 mars à plaisir cette équipe ont
déclaré forfait à la dernière minute et
l'ambiance est moins festive
là on n'est pas encore sera 100% gonds
on sait que il faut vivre au jour le
jour le 10 mars on compte 47 cas
confirmés les deux premiers décès sont
enregistrés dans un ehpad à luz yens le
16 mars le président emmanuel macron
annonce le confinement du pays
une restriction des déplacements et le
report du deuxième tour des municipales
dans les magasins les rayons sont
dévalisés pendant plusieurs jours
le rayon pattes on l'a remplie hier
matin et on commençait à vouloir tout
mettre et des cons remplissait ça
partait donc on essaye de le mettre de
l'europe et une fois par jour parce que
sinon des corrompus et c'est vide le
premier confinement commence
officiellement le 17 mars dans le
département les contrôles de police sont
effectués ici sur l'artère principale de
l'agglomération avenue du centre les
rues sont quasiment désertes
ce mois de mars se termine par une
triste nouvelle le kobe 19 ans porte le
président des hauts-de-seine patrick
devedjian le 28 mars à l'âge de 75 ans
il se battait sur le plan politique pour
faire aboutir la fusion des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine locaux vides 19 une
actualité qui va également rythmer le
reste de l'année dans les yvelines